la homosexualidad no es un delito estas
fueron las palabras del sumo pontífice
de la Iglesia Católica días antes de su
visita a la República democrática del
Congo sin embargo en las mismas
declaraciones el Papa Francisco dijo que
el homosexualidad es un pecado a pesar
de las palabras ambiguas activistas
lgbtiq más saludaron la postura del papa
y consideran que es un paso adelante
para el futuro de las identidades
sexuales diversas en África
la población la población es
predominantemente cristiana y en el
prejuicio cristiano las personas lgbtiq
más a menudo son estigmatizadas y cuando
un representante del cristianismo del
catolicismo tiene las palabras que
promueven la inclusión la aceptación es
algo que anima y por eso estoy
particularmente agradecido por esas
palabras
pero cuando Francisco era Jorge Mario
bergoglio el arzobispo de Buenos Aires
no respaldaba los derechos de la
comunidad lgbtiq más en Argentina el
ahora papá se opuso a la aprobación del
matrimonio igualitario e incluso afirmó
que era una pretensión destructiva del
plan de Dios
a pesar de que la República democrática
del Congo no hace parte de los 67 países
o jurisdicciones en el mundo que
criminaliza el homosexualidad la
discriminación sigue siendo alta
alquilar una propiedad o acceder a
atención médica sigue siendo difícil
para las personas sexualmente diversas